Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to be talking about a
language called Hindus stanny or it's
sometimes called Hindus standing.
Okay.
There are countries with names like
Pakistan,
Afghanistan,
Kazic,
Stan is there a country called
Hindustan?
Well,
kind of at certain points throughout
history at the term,
Hindustan has been used to refer to all
of India,
but more generally it is used to refer
to the area of the northern Indian sub
continent.
The term Hindustan itself is a Persian
term,
meaning the land of the Indus River.
Hindustan Steny is a language that arose
in the Hindustan region.
Maybe you've never heard of Hindu
standing before,
but you've probably heard of Hindi and
Urdu.
Hindi standing is a clery centric
language,
meaning that it's a single language that
has two different standard varieties.
Okay.
Even though Hindi and Urdu are referred
to by different names,
the spoken language is essentially the
same.
Aside from some differences and accent
and maybe local regional vocabulary.
The standard languages,
however,
which are used in writing and in formal
situations have more significant
differences that reflect the cultural
and religious identity of the speakers,
but the development of these two
standard languages is a recent
phenomenon for most of us history.
Hinder standing was a single language
that was referred to by various
different names.
Hindustan he has spoken as a native
language by lots and lots of people.
It depends on how you count it,
but around 324 million people are native
speakers of either Hindi or Urdu.
There are about 258 million speakers of
Hindi in India and about 52 million
speakers of Urdu in India and 14.7
million speakers of through do in
Pakistan and that's referring to native
speakers.
They also function as Lingua Franca is
in very linguistically diverse regions.
There are an additional 214000002nd
language speakers of Hindu standing.
This is perhaps most striking in
Pakistan were only 8% of the people
speak Urdu as a native language,
but over 94 million people speak it as a
second language because it is widely
learned as the language of education.
There are also 120000002nd language
speakers of Hindi in India,
so if we include both native speakers
and second language speakers of both
varieties of Hindu standing,
then there are about 538 million
speakers of the language hinders
standing as a member of the Indo area in
branch of the Indo European language
family and it's a descendant of the Sora
Seine Prek read language.
The language from which all modern Indo
area in language is descended from and
if we go back earlier than the
[inaudible] language,
it is a descendant of Sanskrit,
early forms of Hindu standing developed
between the seventh to 13th century CE,
a time of heavy Islamic influence on the
Indian subcontinent due to conquest by
Central Asian Turkic invaders.
Then in the 13th century CE,
the Deli sultanate,
it began its rule and expanded this
Islamic influence.
Hindu standing was the language of the
common people around Delhi.
While Persian became the official state
language and language of the courts and
the language of the elite.
The Deli sultanate was a Muslim kingdom
which was ruled by a success of Turkic
and Afghan dynasties.
These dynasties were personalized,
meaning that they looked up to and
admired the Persian culture,
so they brought the Persian language and
its literary traditions with them to
understand and they also spoke their own
native languages among them Turkic
languages.
They were followed by the Mughal empire
in 1526 they were another person as to
people of Turkic Mongol descent and like
the Deli salt in it.
They introduced Persian as the official
language of the empire,
the Lingua Franca of the elite people
and the prestigious literary language.
At the same time,
Arabic was influential as a language of
religion during this time Hindustan me,
which was known by different names such
as [inaudible] and they lovey spread
over much of the northern Indian sub
continent as a Lingua Franca.
Although there were some local
differences in vocabulary.
The influence of Persian during these
dynasties as well as the status of
Arabic as the language of religion had
an impact on the Hindu standing
language,
but the degree of that impact,
it depended on the local area and the
culture and the religion of that
community.
For example,
Muslim communities used more Arabic and
Persian words and wrote in the pair,
so Arabic script called Nesta leak while
Hindu communities used more sanskrit
words and wrote in the Devanagari script
in the 18th century,
towards the end of the Mughal empire,
a form of Hindu standing based on the
Kirribilli dialect of Delhi came to
replace Persian as the language of the
elite and soon after under British rule,
it became the official language along
with English.
It was a variety of Hindu standing
containing Persian vocabulary.
Another name for that language started
to be used,
which was Urdu.
That name Urdu is a shortened form of
the Persian phrase is urban,
a Odu,
which means language of the camp.
That is because the language was the
Lingua Franca of the moog out army and
was used in their army camps until this
Persian ised variety of Hindu standing
was made the official language
Hindustan.
He was considered a single language for
all communities with mere local
variations,
but when the [inaudible] variety written
and nostalgic script was made an
official language by the British,
this angered Hindus who thought that the
language should be written in the
Devanagari script,
which is native to the sub continent.
This erupted into a major dispute over
which script the language should be
written in.
Amid this dispute,
the standard language of Hindu standing
began to diverged into two different
languages with Hindi drawing on sense
greed for much of its formal vocabulary
and purging the language of some of it's
Persian and Arabic vocabulary.
Urdu went the other direction,
purging the language of some of its
sense,
great vocabulary and expanding the
amount of Persian and Arabic vocabulary.
But this applies mainly to the standard
written languages with the spoken
language is remaining almost completely
intelligible.
When a Hindi speaker and an Urdu speaker
encounter each other,
they have no problem communicating at
all.
There might be some different vocabulary
that filters down from the literary
language and there might be some
different vocabulary coming from local
dialects and there might be a slightly
different accent,
but generally they are not very
different at all.
In fact,
bollywood movies are created in a kind
of neutral Hindustan.
The language that is usually neither
Hindi nor [inaudible],
it's both.
To do this,
they avoid using literary vocabulary
that is specific to either language and
they focus on the common vocabulary of
the spoken languages.
Let's look at a couple of sentences to
see how similar the two languages are in
casual speech and how they diverged in
the more formal register.
The first sentence means I want to meet
you first in casual Urdu
math.
Now in casual Hindi Ma [inaudible].
So as you can see,
the casual forms are quite similar or
almost the same now in literary or do
map
now in literary Hindi,
[inaudible] Opsm malicky come not hair.
In the literary forms.
You can see that the vocabulary is quite
different.
The next sentence,
I want to know how you are in casual
Urdu
map
now when casual Hindi,
Matt [inaudible] who in literary or do
and now in literary Hindi,
Matt [inaudible].
These examples basically showed that
Hindustan he has a single language but
that literary Urdu and literary kindie
have been crafted to reflect the
different religious and literary
traditions of their speakers.
Of course,
it would be a mistake to think that all
Muslims on the Indian sub continent
speak Urdu and that all Hindus speak
Hindi,
but think of it like this.
For people who specifically speak Hindi
[inaudible] their religion basically
determines which one they speak Hindi or
Urdu.
It would also be a mistake to think that
Urdu is the Pakistani language.
While Hindi is the Indian language,
Urdu is the official language of
Pakistan along with English,
but in fact only 8% of the population
are native speakers of Urdu.
As I said before,
numerous other languages are spoken in
Pakistan and the most widely spoken one
is actually Punjabi,
but Urdu is the lingua franca and
virtually everybody learns it.
In India,
Hindi and English are the official
languages at the national level,
but each state is free to choose its own
official languages too.
There are a total of 20 recognized
official languages at the state level
and that includes Urdu.
Urdu is not just the language of
Pakistan,
it's also an official language in eight
states in India,
including the Deli Capitol region.
It is spoken by 51.5
million native speakers in India and
that's 3.5
times greater than the number of Urdu
native speakers in Pakistan.
So how hard is it to learn,
hinder standing either Hindi or Urdu?
Well,
if you're a speaker of an Indo European
language than you already speak a
language that's related to hinder
standing.
So most of the grammatical concepts will
be familiar to you,
but there will also be some challenging
differences as well.
If we look back at our sentence from
before in English,
it translates something like I you meet,
want English is an Svo language.
While Hindu standing is generally Sov,
that means subject,
object,
verb and the verb goes at the end of the
clause.
You will also notice that meat comes
before once sold.
The auxiliary verb or the helping verb
comes after the main verb.
At the very end of the clause or
sentence.
In Hindi,
there are also feminine and masculine
nouns as well as three noun cases,
but these three known cases seems
significantly simpler than some other
languages that you may have encountered.
Hungarian.
One of the hardest things about learning
Hindi or Urdu just might be that so many
people on the Indian subcontinent are
fluent in English,
so it might be hard to get them to speak
any other language than English with
you,
especially highly educated people,
but if you spend time with the common
people that you meet every day,
then you'll have plenty of chances to
practice.
Speaking about Hindi and Urdu can be
confusing because they used to be
considered one language and now in terms
of spoken communication,
they are still essentially one language.
Whether someone speaks Hindi or whether
they speak Urdu,
depends more on their cultural and
religious identity or do speakers
identify with Islamic and Persian
heritage and its literary tradition.
While Hindi speakers identify with sense
greet and the Hindu religion and its
literary tradition,
they speak the same language but on top
of that spoken language.
Each group has adopted a formal literary
tradition that emphasizes its preferred
cultural and religious identity as a
learner of the language.
Assuming that you want to converse and
communicate with people.
Then learning either variety,
we'll give you access to the other one
and that's a total number of 538 million
people and with a diaspora all over the
world,
even outside of the sub continent,
you will have countless opportunities to
practice and make new connections using
the [inaudible] language.
And that brings us to the end of this
video.
Speakers of Hindi or Urdu,
we'd like to hear your comments down
below.
Tell us your experience with
communicating with people who speak the
other variety of Hindu standing.
Is it the same language to you?
How much difference is there?
How much similarity is there?
Let us know in the comments.
I would also like to thank everyone who
made new patriot and contributions since
the last video I made and also to people
who gave one time donations through the
blue support button on the channel page.
And also I'd like to say thanks to those
people who have offered to help out with
some of the videos on the Geo focus
channel and today is somebody also
offered to help out by submitting some
subtitles or captions in their native
language.
For some of my videos,
that would be a great thing.
If you'd like to do that too,
then that's very welcome and I would be
very thankful.
Any help like that that you can do to
support the channel is fine by me.
Thank you for watching.
Have a nice day.